guten morgen vom ersten tag der japaner
und herzlich willkommen auf der größten
flugshow europas wo sich heute dort bei
uns erwarten wird ist ein breit
gefächertes flugprogramm wunderschönsten
wetter also wir neun stunden volles
programm angefangen vom den besten
kunstflugstaffeln der europäischen union
natürlich auch mit beteiligung von
österreichische bundesheer wir vom
eurofighter haben einen kompletten
display ein solo display und natürlich
auch einen tiger hilfe und nicht zu
vergessen es gibt natürlich auch ein
hubschrauber programm dazu auch die
weltpremiere von web sind es kein und
somit wünschen wir uns euch einen
wunderschönen tag hier auf der rv auf
den ersten tag konnten technik